wir brauchen also Konsequenzen sonst
ändert sich nichts da sind wir auch
schon mittendrin in ihrer ganz
persönlichen Geschichte sie waren Chef
vom Gesundheitsamt Aichach Friedberg und
sie haben sehr früh schon sehr deutlich
Kritik geübt an den corona-maßnahmen
dann wurden sie ihres Jobs enthoben ganz
herzlich wer hat das getan wer hat es
getan also das ist natürlich immer in
unserem beamtensystem kann man das immer
schwer sagen wer hat es getan also meine
vorgesetzte Stelle die Regierung von
Schwaben hat mich informiert dass ich
mehr oder weniger von heute auf morgen
abgeordnet wäre auf andere Stelle ich
sollte da angeblich gebraucht werden zu
dem Inhalt darf ich relativ wenig sagen
Hintergrund ist aber und es ist kein
Geheimnis mehr ich habe die
corona-maßnahmen der also von der
bayerischen Politik aber auch der
Bundesrepublik natürlich auch
kritisiert und ich habe das aus
fachlicher Sicht getan ich habe nie
irgendjemanden herabgesetzt habe vorher
im Innenverhältnis
kritisiert das nennt man dann
Demonstration Demonstrationsrecht als
Polizei als als Beamter die steht mir so
zu das ist aber auch die Politik
kritisiert sehr schön
Ministerpräsidenten kritisiert naja ich
habe die Maßnahmen kritisiert und das
ist so Unterschied das ist schon ein
Unterschied und auch als Beamter das
muss ich einfach so sagen es steht mir
das zu ich bin Arzt ich bin Beamter und
Leiter eines Gesundheitsamtes und mir
ist der Schutz der Bevölkerung
anvertraut worden mit meinem Amt und
wenn ich erkenne an der Basis das
bestimmte Maßnahmen nicht so gut laufen
und einfach an Schaden andere
Bevölkerung anrichten dann ist es meine
Pflicht das zu sagen und das lasse ich
mir auch nicht nehmen zumal ich auch vom
Fach bin ja frag sie das weil ich mich
frage was ging in ihnen vor hatten sie
dann das Gefühl dieser Anruf der muss
von ganz oben gekommen sein ich weiß
dass der von ganz oben kam weil mir
meine Vorgesetzten das auch so zukommen
haben lassen denn man hat mir immer
wieder versucht und so wurde das dann
auch immer erzählt man man hat versucht
mich oder man man sollte mich einbremsen
ich sollte nicht nach außen in die
Bevölkerung gehen und Interviews geben
denn das würde sehr wahrscheinlich oder
können es ja wahrscheinlich die
Bevölkerung verunsichern und ich habe
diese Annahme glauben Sie Markus Söder
persönlich hat das weiß ich nicht das
weiß ich nicht da kann ich nur
spekulieren dabei will ich es auch
belassen alles was ich gesagt habe Komma
in meinen Interviews nachlesen man kann
es auf meinem Twitter-Account nachlesen
ich habe 2021 ein Buch rausgegeben
Diagnose Panik die MEDA drin kann man
nachlesen da steht eigentlich alles drin
was ich intern immer kritisiert habe und
was ich an den Maßnahmen kritisiert habe
und ich finde schon noch mal als
Fachmann ich bin Epidemiologe Facharzt
für öffentliche Gesundheitswesen steht
mir diese fachliche Kritik zu und wie
man natürlich jetzt auch sehen kann
hatte ich auch
in der Verantwortung gefühlt sie sagen
heute auch ganz klar jetzt aber jetzt
müssen Konsequenzen folgen jetzt müssen
deutliche Konsequenzen folgen und ihr
Thema ist heute sie sagen ganz klar
jetzt sollte der Gesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach ihren Job verlieren
jetzt haben sie ihre Zeit und ihre
Kamera
nein das ist vollkommen klar also Karl
Lauterbach muss als Gesundheitsminister
zurücktreten beziehungsweise ist sehr
schön wenn er wenn
vom Bundeskanzler
zurückgepfiffen würde warum weil Karl
Lauterbach ganz einfach wir fachlich
noch charakterlich für dieses Amt
geeignet das sind zu viele Fehler
passiert man man sieht es auch immer
wieder sich artikuliert was alles
erzählt es sind viele Dinge falsch die
dir erzählt hat und nun ähm schiebte
diese Dinge die jetzt immer mehr ans
Tageslicht kommen dass wir Kritiker doch
recht hatten die schiebte jetzt auf
seine Experten zu vorher dass ich feiern
lassen als Experte plötzlich wäre da
kein Experte mehr sondern er hat nur auf
die Wissenschaft gehört also ist relativ
viel falsch gelaufen natürlich nicht nur
unter der ägidee von Karl Lauterbacher
musste ich schon sehen wir hatten vorher
andere Bundesregierung die ist nicht
mehr da da muss man vielleicht überlegen
ob es nicht da Amtshaftungsansprüche
gibt aber jetzt haben wir einen
Bundesgesundheitsminister der
tatsächlich in meiner in meinen Augen
fachlich und persönlich nicht in der
Lage ist dieses Amt auszufüllen und
deshalb muss er gehen das ist ihre
Forderung hier heute und sie verbinden
das natürlich auch mit der Verantwortung
wie sie getragen haben sie haben auch
ihre ganz persönliche Geschichte in
dieser Pandemie jetzt sind sie vor
Gericht das ganze ist an einer Klage
sagen sie uns nehmen Sie jetzt einmal
mit wollen sie wollen sie ihren alten
Job gerne zurück haben geht es Ihnen
einen auch darum dass sie zeigen ich
kann mich wehren und vielleicht geht es
auch andere Menschen so wie mir sehen
sie sich da auch einfach in der
Verantwortung also das mit dem Gericht
ist mittlerweile beschädigt aber da
mache ich gar nicht so viel darüber
erzählen
hat aber auch damit überhaupt nichts zu
tun ich möchte natürlich rehabilitiert
werden denn ich wurde aufs schärfste
diskreditiert ich wurde von heute auf
morgen meines Amtes in toben ich wurde
erst abgeordnet dann weiter versetzt
und das aufgrund meiner meiner
Kritik und ich war ja nicht alleine
sondern es gibt ja viele Kritiker die in
diesem in diesem pandemiezeiten
diskreditiert worden sind und da erwarte
ich ganz einfach dass die alle wieder
rehabilitiert werden und die die dazu
beigetragen haben diese Menschen zu
diskreditieren die müssen ihre
Konsequenzen ziehen und die müssen
tatsächlich ihren Job verlieren das ist
ja ein Perversität fast nicht zu
überbieten was mit uns gemacht worden
ist wir fanden kein Gehör in den
öffentlichen rechtlichen Sendern
die Kritiker also wichen wir aus auf die
sogenannten alternativen Medien und
allein durch dieses ausweichen wurden
wir gebranntmarkt man hat sich ja gar
nicht mehr mit unseren Argumenten
beschäftigen
wo die die die Rechten sind die
querschuhe dass da Alexander kekulle
dort war und nach mir noch ganz andere
der Heribert Brandl das hat überhaupt
gar keine interessiert es hat keinen
mehr interessieren
an dem Tag es sie quasi ihren Job
verloren haben sie wurden versetzt und
sie Vertrauen verloren hat sie das
verletzt hat sie das enttäuscht haben
sie das fast schon erwartet weil ihnen
vielleicht vorher signalisiert wurde
gehen sie damals nicht zu weit also es
wurde mir so in der Form überhaupt
nichts signalisiert gar nichts in
keinster Weise ich habe tatsächlich
damit gerechnet dass das was ich mache
Konsequenzen in irgendeine Art und Weise
haben könnte aber man hat mit mir vorher
überhaupt nicht darüber abgebrochen und
natürlich hat es mich getroffen denn
noch mal ich war gerade auf dem
Höhepunkt meiner Karriere wahrscheinlich
wäre es sogar noch ein Stück weiter
gegangen ich lebe auch immer noch in
diesem Landkreis wo ich vorher tätig war
also man ist nicht nur beruflich
diskreditiert und isoliert sondern
tatsächlich auch privat und persönlich
und meine Karriere ist bis zum heutigen
Tag und hat sie nichts geändert die ist
kaputt die ist zerstört fertig ja als
Beamter kann nichts wenn so bleibt wie
es jetzt ist sehe ich kein Land mehr ich
kann quasi nur noch auf meine
Pensionierung warten und das ist alles
andere als schön und deshalb erwarte ich
mir natürlich schon eine Rehabilitierung
denn wir Kritiker und ich jetzt in dem
Fall wir haben unseren Kopf hingehalten
und haben frühzeitig gesagt dass
bestimmte Maßnahmen nicht richtig sind
ich denke zum Beispiel an die
Schulschließungen
maskenpflicht genauso habe ich mir
rechtzeitig und frühzeitig habe ich
gesagt bitte maskenpflicht auf
bevölkerungsebene das wird dann immer
gern falsch verstanden
naja es ist ein tragischer Fall von dem
wir glaube ich viele haben ne also und
der Gesundheitsminister vor Jens Spahn
schrieb ja glaube ich letztens ein Buch
über wir werden uns viel verzeihen
müssen wenn ich den Titel richtig im
Kopf habe und ich glaube in der genau in
der Situation sind wir und wenn ich die
Ausführungen höre erinnere ich mich noch
gut daran das Ende letzten Jahres die
Grünen hier in Berlin noch die
maskenpflicht wieder einführen wollten
jetzt haben wir sie zum Glück auch
abgeschafft aber wir hatten natürlich
schon auch irgendwo den Punkt wo wo eine
gewisse
große Staatsgläubigkeit und eine gewisse
Monstranz der Unterwürfigkeit genutzt
wurde um sozusagen glaube ich auch Panik
zu schüren und ähm ich glaube man muss
ja auch bei den Kritikern unterscheiden
und das ist eben das Problem was
wirklich nicht gemacht wurde ne also wir
alle kennen zu Schriften wo ich mir auch
denke mit dir brauche ich mich jetzt
vielleicht nicht darüber unterhalten
aber wenn von Fachleute ernsthafte
Kritikpunkte kommen da muss ich mich
damit auseinandersetzen und es wurde
nicht gemacht
in der Regierung mit trotzdem
Gesundheitsminister am Kabinettstisch
ist er noch der geeignete
Gesundheitsminister wir suchen uns die
Minister der SPD nicht aus sondern
müssen auf dem Vorschlag der SPD hoffen
dass sie da gute Leute würden das können
sie so interpretieren nein das habe ich
schon auch ich glaube sogar schon in
diesem Tisch hier gesagt dass ich der
Meinung wenn das das Karl Lauterbach
sicherlich nicht die beste Besetzung als
Bundesgesundheitsminister ist aber das
Vorschlagsrecht liegt hier bei der SPD
dementsprechend muss die SPD erklären
was denn gut ist analbach
es werden jetzt immer mehr für seine
eingeräumte Kistler jetzt heißt es auch
Seiten des Gesundheitsminister die
Schulschließungen hätten nicht sein
dennoch die Forderungen von Herrn Pirna
ist bisher nicht erfüllt haben wir keine
rücktrittskultur mehr nein wir haben
keine rücktrittskultur mehr haben auch
keine verantwortungskultur mehr ist
herrscht die machtarithmetik in einer
derart starren Weise dass sie in
Grenzbereiche des demokratisch überhaupt
noch vertretbaren sich hinein bewegt das
bedauere ich sehr sehr wir erleben zwar
von Ihnen hier im Nebensatz geschildert
nicht nur eine Verengung der
debattenräume sondern auch eine
Verengung der Zuständigkeiten das heißt
sie die Fachkompetenz wird geringer
geschätzt es ist viel wichtiger heute
vielleicht noch viel wichtiger als
früher sich innerhalb der Partei
Karriere nach oben gedient zu haben den
Rest soll angeblich der Apparat
Schultern auch der Apparat konnte Frau
Lamprecht nicht zu einer guten
Verteidigungsministerin machen z.B und
Frau Spiegel nicht zu einer guten
Bundesfamilienministerin also da gerät
die Apparat schick denke an ihre Grenzen
die Wirklichkeit hat einen Kritiker wie
ihn rehabilitiert es sollte der Staat
ihn auch rehabilitieren und meine große
Sorge ist dass wir alle mit Gewissen
sagen Verwundungen an der Seele die wir
uns vielleicht heute noch gar nicht so
ganz entstehen wollen aus dieser
corona-engführung der Debatte uns
herausbewegen dass wir damals gelernt
haben es gibt Zeiten da ist es nötig
Herrn Scholz dem Bundeskanzler zu folgen
wenn der sagt es gibt keine roten Linien
es gibt immer rote Läden ist ein ganz
dummer Satz den Satz hat nun mit Blick
auf den Ukraine Krieg Frau Esslingen die
SPD-Vorsitzende wiederholt auch da gebe
es keine roten Linien in der
Unterstützung der Ukraine die rote Linie
in Deutschland ist das Grundgesetz ist
die Tatsache dass der Souverän nur einer
ist und nämlich das Volk und leider
haben wir eine übergriffige Exekutive in
der Corona Debatte erlebt und ich kann
nur hoffen dass diese Übergriffigkeit
bei anderen Debatten bei anderen Krisen
nicht wieder aus der Mottenkiste
hervorgeholt wird wie viele verwöhnungen
an der Seele glaubst du haben wir davon
getragen durch diese Krise und wie wenig
übernimmt die Politik jetzt dafür die
Verantwortung der erste muss man sagen
die SPD mochte Lauterbach ja eigentlich
auch nicht wirklich viele muss man mal
klarstellen und diese Entscheidung ging
ja eigentlich mehr von Stolz aus und es
gab auch so Moment da war das eher ein
Talkshow Erfolg dass er dann auch gesagt
Gesundheitsminister wurde und das gäbe
viel es hätte viele Möglichkeiten
gegeben wo er komplett falsch lag und so
viel Panik geschürt hat als
Gesundheitsminister wo er hätte
zurücktreten müssen wo andere schon
längst hätten zurücktreten müssen und
hätte man das viel früher getan also es
wäre recht schwer passiert
wahrscheinlich dann hätte man sich
natürlich auch eingestehen müssen dass
man eine Fehlbesetzung hier hatte und
dass man das Panik auch eine gewisse
voraussetzung war anscheinend für diesen
Posten und ähm ja also
deine Frage jetzt Wunden wir wie viele
Verletzungen auf der Seele haben und wie
viel an wie wenig Verantwortung
letztendlich dafür auch übernommen wird
ja also im Prinzip nie zurück es tut
niemals zurück also im Prinzip gibt es
auch gar keine Verantwortung auf allen
Ebenen also wenn wir jetzt äh die nehmen
die Kinder wie die gelitten haben mit
Schulschließung mit den Masken tragen
und auch deren Eltern wie wie Menschen
gelitten haben ausgegrenzt zu werden wie
sie also oder auch Menschen die einfach
es gibt es hatten auf die Straße
gegangen sind wir hatten das schon oft
hier in zum thematisiert die dann an den
rechten Rand gedrückt wurden von der
Politik wir haben auf so vielen Ebenen
Menschen die
so viel Folgen tragen psychisch seelisch
körperlich von der Pandemie und vor
allem von der Politik und ich glaube
auch gar nicht mehr daran dass ein
Politiker sich dahin stellt und wirklich
sagt ich habe ein Fehler gemacht und
mehrere Fehler und ich trage hier die
Verantwortung und zeige das und das auf
ich glaube nicht dass es passiert und es
scheinser als würde es jetzt eigentlich
das nächste fast geben es melden sich
immer mehr Menschen Herr Körner die
Impfschäden haben die nach der Impfung
an Krankheiten leiden die eigentlich
teilweise am Leben gar nicht mehr
teilnehmen können ist das das nächste
große fast das aufgemacht werden muss
auch dazu wenig Verantwortung übernommen
wird diese große fast ich kann mich
daran erinnern ich saß in einer anderen
talkshirt ging es um den Herrn Kimmich
hier im Fußball der sich nicht impfen
lassen wollte und ich sagte damals
vollkommen Recht weil einfach sagte na
ja so diese langzeitfolgende sein und
nicht so ganz klar jeder der mit Medizin
zu tun hat der weiß dass Medikamente
Nebenwirkungen haben können das geht gar
nicht anders da ja dass das wurde aber
gerade bei der Impfung überhaupt das
wurde komplett ausgeblendet und und das
ist ein Unsinn und der Lauterbach hat es
noch getwittert und der hat bis heute
nicht zurückgenommen zumindest nicht auf
Twitter das ist keine Nebenwirkungen bzw
die Impfung nebenwirkungsfrei ist das
ist absoluter Unsinn und wir schauen
dazu wenig hin und diese diese Impfung
die wird beworben und beworben und immer
noch und immer noch und es gibt longovic
und das will ich auch gar nicht
verneinen das kennen wir von anderen
Erkrankungen aber genauso gut aber
natürlich müssen wir auch die Leute
jetzt in den Fokus nehmen die sagen nach
der Impfung habe ich bestimmt die
Schäden aber das wird ausgeblendet und
warum weil man mit einer Wucht diese
Impfung über Deutschland gestreut hat
und zwar dann auch noch mit einer
sektoralen Impfpflicht eine absoluten
unglücklichen und natürlich dieses
vollkommene unsinnige zwei g ja und
damit haben ein riesen Fass aufgemacht
hätte man alles freiwillig gelassen auch
die Masken aber vor allem auch das
Impfen dass man einfach nur eine
Empfehlung ausgesprochen hätte für
bestimmte Personengruppen dann wäre das
alles gar nicht so schlimm geworden auch
nicht die Spaltung und dann hätten sich
in Ruhe auch mal diese Impfschäden
angucken können und ich bin mir sicher
man hätte die dann ganz anders da
aufarbeiten können jetzt ist es aber
fast nicht möglich denn mit jedem
Impfschaden der jetzt aufkommt und dem
man nachweisen kann bröckelt das ganze
System und das ist brandgefährlich für
die Politik Einsatz vielleicht nur weil
sie den Kimmich erwähnen das ist
wirklich ein ein Dokument der Schande
man kann es heute noch anschauen dieses
inquisitorische Interview dass er da im
zweiten deutschen Fernsehen im
Sportstudio gegeben hat oder gegeben hat
müssen auf Anraten seines Vereins er
wurde wirklich peinlich gefragt das war
eine mitarbeiterliche Gesprächsführung
im schlechten Sinne er sollte zu Kreuze
kriechen hat es dann später auch gemacht
er musste Abbitte leisten vor einem
Millionenpublikum Ersatz zerknirscht aus
unglücklich er hat letztendlich dann die
schuldformel gesprochen die man für ihn
erwarten hat erwartet hat also leider
Gottes haben auch weite Teile der Medien
dermaßen versagt innerhalb der
corona-pandemie dass man sich wie ein
Vertrauensverlust nachhaltige Art in die
Medien eigentlich gar nicht beschweren
kann ich möchte nur ganz kurz an was
erinnern zum Beispiel
infektionsschutzgesetzter Paragraph 28c
ja der gibt immer noch so steht's auf
jeden Fall drin ähm die Möglichkeit dass
der Gesetzgeber wieder eine Verordnung
treffen kann dass man wieder
impfen kann und das nur geimpfte
bestimmte Dinge machen dürfen und die
ungeimpften eben nicht und alles wird
abgestellt auf diese Immunität die haben
wir aber nicht wir haben mit dieser
Impfung zum Beispiel keine Immunität es
wurde aber ganz ganz lange erzählt diese
Impfung würde uns aus der Pandemie
bringen die sie Impfung würde uns immun
machen das wissen wir aber schon ganz
lange das ist nicht so ist die
Impfpflicht die sektorale Impfpflicht
galt aber noch bis zu Ende es war keiner
in der Lage zu sagen wir heben jetzt
diese Impfpflicht einfach mal und sie
wurde ja auch eine kontrolliert ne also
das ist ja noch das ist ja das ist ja
noch der nächste Punkt also wir haben
die Impfpflicht die sektorale auch immer
sehr kritisch gesehen insbesondere war
ja auch wirklich viele Fachleute auch
Professor schräg und sowas klar gemacht
haben es hilft ja auch nichts und ähm
ich fand es in Berlin wirklich
bezeichnet wie wir hier eine
Gesundheitssenatorin haben die dann auch
sich hinstellen und sagt mir
kontrollieren es auch gar nicht aber wir
müssen beibehalten im Zweifel sogar
verlängern wo ich dann auch mich
irgendwann also was machen wir als
Gesetzgeber für Gesetze also das haben
wir hier die Oppositionsrolle und ich
glaube auch das war auf Bundesebene
zumindest ganz gut hinwirken dass
vieles gebremst wurde von der Panik die
sonst noch noch weiter gelaufen wäre
aber das er schon Punkt also wir wir
machen Regelungen die wir nicht
kontrollieren können und wo wir uns
ernsthaft über die Sinnhaftigkeit Fragen
müssen und
das müssen wir aufarbeiten vor allem
werden gerade in den Fall kenn ich hier
viele die sich dagegen entschieden haben
sich impfen zu lassen haben sich das
überhaupt gar nicht mehr getraut zu
sagen und als ich mir sie genauer
angeschaut habe habe ich bei Twitter
auch gesehen sie haben Impfstatus privat
machen sie das genau ist diesem Grund
weil man sich eigentlich nicht trauen
kann einfach zu sagen ich lass mich
nicht helfen nein nicht aus dem Grund
sondern weiß was höchst persönliches ist
und ich habe das mal eine einem
Vorgesetzten gesagt
die wollten das Wissen und dann sagte
ich wenn sie mir jetzt in Ordnung Stelle
sagen ob sie heute Stuhlgang hatten und
in der früh Sex mit ihrem Partner oder
mit einer weitere dann beantworte ich
Ihnen Ihre Frage denn das ist was ganz
privates das sind medizinische Dinge und
die spielten früher überhaupt gar keine
Rolle und ich könnte mich wirklich tot
ärgern wenn ich auf Twitter immer
gelesen habe oh Gott jetzt ist jemand
positiv wir wünschen dir gute Besserung
Gott sei Dank bist du geimpft und so
weiter das spielte alles vorher
überhaupt keine Rolle die sind private
Dinge das sind medizinische Dinge die
dürfen überhaupt gar nicht Einzug halten
ins Privatleben das geht Sie sie und sie
nichts an ob ich
würden Sie heute Menschen empfehlen sich
impfen zu lassen das kommt drauf an das
kommt tatsächlich darauf an also ich
habe ganz früh gesagt diese Impfung die
Empfehlung würde ich so machen wie bei
der Grippe also angelehnt an die Grippe
ab 60 aufwärts wohl in der Gruppen ähm
und natürlich auch jüngere die bestimmte
Vorerkrankungen haben aber aber jetzt
kommt mit einer richtigen ordentliche
Aufklärung und als Fahrrad steht ist mir
ganz einfach nicht zu darüber zu
befinden wenn jemand sagt nein ich will
nicht geimpft werden dann muss ich das
als Arzt hinnehmen hauptsache ich habe
meine
Aufklärungspflicht erledigt aber ich
darf gar keinen drängen und für mich war
das dermaßen schlimm das sogenannte
impfkommandos in die Altenheime
eingerückt sind dann haben die Leute
einfach geimpft und es kam mir keiner
sagen wirklich dass die ordentlich
aufgeklärt worden sind denn ich weiß aus
zahlreichen Mails dass Menschen geimpft
worden sind die am Ende ihres Lebens
waren und da rede ich jetzt nicht von
Jahren sondern es ging zum Teil um
Stunden und Tage ja die vor sich hin
verzeihen Sie mir den Ausdruck vor sich
hin vegetierten und trotzdem noch
geimpft wurden in den letzten Stunden
ihres Lebens und das ist für mich
absolut unethisch also ja Impfung kann
man darüber reden aber bitte man muss
ordentlich aufklären und muss ordentlich
aufgeben man braucht dafür
verhältnismäßig kalt
und man muss das unbedingt unbedingt
freiwillig machen ich habe letztens so
ein Bild gehabt da habe ich mir auch
gedacht diese Verhältnismäßigkeit ist so
verloren gegangen dass stand ich am
Straßenrand und ein Auto ist vorbei
gefahren das hat also eine Person drin
und die hat eine Maske getragen
alleine im Auto wo ich mir gedacht habe
also das gibt's ja wirklich und es gibt
so Situationen also
ich bin härter Fan der leitet man
momentan immer aber
ich hatte maskenpflicht noch im Zug ne
mit der S-Bahn beim hinfahren muss sich
die Maske tragen im Stadion Ängste Raum
alles eng gar kein Problem also es war
halt auch idiotisch was wir da zum Teil
gemacht haben und es war den Menschen
auch nicht mehr erklärbar und ich glaube
großes Problem wenn man vor allem bei
den ganzen seelischen Bereichen haben
das merke ich momentan auch
bei Kindern ganz ganz großes Thema dass
die Politik auf keinen Fall aus den
Augen verlieren darf